Komputery kwantowe nie będą nadawać się do rozwiązywania
wszystkich problemów, ale jest kilka klas problemów
i potencjalnych zastosowań, w których spodziewamy się,
że obliczenia kwantowe wywrą wpływ.
Należą do nich symulacje, takie jak
modelowanie procesów i systemów zachodzących
w naturze; przeszukiwanie i optymalizacja,
polegające na szukaniu najlepszego lub
optymalnego rozwiązania w sytuacji z
wieloma możliwymi odpowiedziami; a także matematyka
i przetwarzanie danych o złożonej strukturze,
w tym zastosowania w uczeniu maszynowym.
Algorytmy kwantowe podchodzą w nowy sposób do
tego rodzaju problemów, wykorzystując
unikalne cechy fizyki kwantowej, takie jak
superpozycja, interferencja i splątanie.
Zwykłe komputery utykają
przy eksploracji pewnych obszarów przestrzeni obliczeniowej
i nie są w stanie znaleźć tych wzorców.
Komputery kwantowe są wyposażone w
dodatkowe możliwości lub zwiększoną wydajność
dla niektórych problemów, wynikającą z ich kwantowej natury.
Żeby w pełni zrozumieć potencjał komputerów kwantowych,
trzeba zagłębić się w teorię złożoności obliczeniowej —
dziedzinę informatyki skupioną na
mierzeniu i porównywaniu nakładu obliczeniowego potrzebnego
do rozwiązywania różnych rodzajów problemów.
Daje to użyteczne ramy
do opisywania różnych przyspieszeń
i klas problemów, które napotykamy
w obliczeniach.